vertical je en parler je vais en parler
ok alors arrête on ferme les portes on
ferme tout et là tu as des gens qui
euh voilà tu vas rester là je vais leur
dire qu'il passe les cons un peu dessus
tu descends tu te poses que tu fermes
les on ferme tout
ouais on va se
démerder tu es là y tu es là y c'est bon
c'est bon vas-y attends avant d'ouvrir
la porte la prochaine fois s'il te plaît
que ce soit vraiment l'atterrissage fini
que je te que je fini moi exuse-moi tu
vois faut checker la queue avec S
gros d'accord bon quand tu cé
bon fa un plan là oui super super
super c'est joli ça en plus magnifique
ça
vas-y molo vas-y molo
ok oh c'est marrant dans le coton c'est
super beau
ça
bien
regarder justement à la limite ça fait
monter sil te regarde pas quoi presque
tu
vois façon il vont paser longtemps il un
moment ils vont se calmer ils
vont merde on pe rien faire j'aurais pu
Mo il aur pu le faire si aur faire à cé
bien s àheure le blanc on dirait sur un
truc de neige c'est
magnifique fais gaffe tu souffles fais
gaffe tu souffles tu souffles souffles
mon plus haut
toutous oh la B laère mer
mer que je dégage
sinon la prise
de c'est bon c'est
bon monte encore monte encore je je suis
tout en train de
monter
ah c'est marrant regarde mec
allongé
il font les
cons allez j Jes j vais un peu
plus c'est marrant quand il monte le
coton comme
ça
donc les voilà nos enfants qui
travaillent
ouis il sont tous des enfants des jeunes
quoi
cul il y en a un qui va baisser son Frid
c'est tu m'entends oui moi je monterai
plus ha un petit peu to quand son moins
présent peut-être moins regarder une
sortie B sort estce que je peux pas mon
là je suis tout sur bras Vy coupe on a
eu l'ombre sur la sortie pour info oua
truc allez vas-y ça
tour on y va
doucement
ah il pass tout c'est
génial
V de la neige ça c'est nul parce que
l'utre fait je
laun
bien vasy
redescends contre jour oua bien
sûr
ça marche
pas
mal onommencer par que
c'est
att joli avec les heres derrière voilà
c'est super beau
ça vol on s'en fout
on con derrière en plus
tuis
de la gueule comme ça c'est qu'il font
les cons
quoi tu diras un sac ça pour être un sac
qui qui doit transporter
c'est pas mal avec le sac en
l'impression que c'est un il le fait pas
pour nous voilà c'est un plus naturel
éloigner un peu fr ce que je suis en
train de faire céit pour éliminer la
maison tu vois
ouais super super
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça il MOS les
cons ouais
voilà pu là ça devent plus
naturel verticale tout à
l'heure
oh le joli volet dis quand je vais
attraper la
maison tu la prends la maison c'est pas
grave pas non
plus un de Ch c'est joli on Fa autre
version
voilà
doucement
sou VO coupe ah non c'est pas sorti oh
yes ah
oui voilà un peu pas un peu
pas doucement
doucement attends je comme ça alors
maintenant on va prendre un peu plus de
risque un peu plus de risque un pe sur
la droite ça tu prend plus sur la droite
du du champu à droite des champs j'ai
tout à l'heure tu avais tous les les
arbres tu vois prends les arbres en
grand à droite
allez plus grand en attends je fais la
se ch pu vasy sors
ça ok coup St s'il te
plaît comme ça les champ tous les champs
aour
pas joli voilà
voilà va faire d'autes
demain
moi ce que je voulais vous dire c'était
de
Tom t c'est génial ça regarde ah génial
génial génial génial ça c'est
super
yes
je suis
rproché j'uris pas la
maison tu vas commencer à la
voir commencer à
voir c'est pas très grave tu l'as tu
l'asê sur c'est
Bonten donc ce que je voulais essayer de
dire si
ça coupe
vas-y c'est juste du champ et le T
derrière attends fait ça
ouais c'est exactement ça c'est
super
ok attends attends je
termine tu descends max j'ai bien je on
verra voilà c'estjà plus comme ça on
sent beaucoup plus de champ de coton
voilà je vais prendre un peu de vitesse
pour ou pas qu'il a peur pas qu'il ai
peur
super il ramasse encore il continue ouis
oui oui ça continue génial c'est super
beau ça c'est super beau comme plan ça
c'est vraiment Jol quand même ou c'est
bien c'est bien
chier il ramass attends attendsends
attends attends attends il ramasse
j'arrive la poussière allez coupe mais
ça va VO très tout c'est
magnifique le mec devant et tout c'est
sublime
ça vas-y faismoi petite descente monte
oui voilà DESC on pe tourner si vous
voulez qu'on tourne un petit peu ver la
gauche on y est après je vais taper un
peu de ser avec le coton en amorce voilà
voilà
le me derrière pas mieux avec le
derrière s'habitu à nous c'est bien
ça unu statique mais bon
qui tour tout le
temps
ok partout ok attends je vais reste
là
pas allez
4 aussi un plan génial c'est la bonne
femme dev le coton son bébé je
sa très bien très bien ça ce que tu fais
génial mer pas
vu allez vas-y travaille
trava
avec la branche de
l'AR je marrête
ok je
reviens
àite
les il ramasse ou pas
oui ah merde il y a un mec en jaune qui
arrive à
côté
pas tourour dans
less mais d'Ar
part
bien à droite il y en a une qui va
déverser a une qui va déverser regarde
le coton sur la
têtein jus
coup
oui pas de
mouvement
dommage
l'arbre est pr dans
le Meti plus
large la vach derrière c'est Ji auss
regarde avec la vache derrière quand
même passe quelque chose là c'est super
beau ça c'est super sous
j'adore C de soleil sur le truc
tu peux tu peux bouger un
peu prendre de là dans dans l' du coton
c'est joli aussi il y en a pas
mal ouais ça fait un are pas mal dans
les arbres dans les arbres comme ça il
ramasse le coton de loin là c'est beau
d'Illes regarde dans les
arbres les sair on va se remettre dans
l'axe attends il va les sair là il y a
un mec qui arrive avec un sac qui va
vider son sac je préféis que tu fasses
les mecs qui ramassent dans les ouais
mais
regarde non ça te va ouais j'y vais
attends attends j'arrive c'est joli des
mecs en rouge
c'est très joli ça regarde un peu
malheureusement mais regarder
he pas
rester AR il vont à V plusuper de
nous une branche dans les mains superbe
oh attends dépêche-toi je me
dépêche je me dépêche me dépêche le plus
rapide possible
ok c'est
bon
joli ça c'est petite ambiance de gens
qui ramassent de
coton les autres qui se Barr c'est mieux
quand Mme VO ça fait
plus loc
quandme
t-shirtach
on sent bien le côté artisanal on a fait
des trucs auunis avec
tracteurs qui RAM la M je faire
vol merci tu peux CPER
St je garde cet arbre j'ai pas regardé
je regardis mes aiguilles
contraireè
voil je
décale
rest ok j'ai pas compris ok ok
avance
voil fr ça l'arrange pour mur comme tu
veux moi je pensais que de partir dans
la matière avant ça permettait de monter
quoi ouis mais tu vois comme il le
trouve pas bien
jeass et après on fera l'autre ça tourne
c'est c'est bon pour
moi tu peux tu peux prendre l' voit l'AR
en
grand derrière c'est peumage vra vra
Rais couper la tête voil ça voilà c'est
joli comme ça voilà absolument tu as
raison
yes laisse se pencher là ah mer
mer ça c'est pas
utilisable pas utilis c'est pour ça
qu'il faut de la vitesse ok attends
essayons quand même encore un petit
chouille quand
même avance un peu Fran obligé de tu
mais c'est le plan pourra le faire
qu'une fois voilà c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon attends attends je vais te
dire 1 2 3 3 4 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 ça vole
ça VO 14 allez vas-y
va qu' s'arrête de nous
regarder allez
travaille
allez domage pas un petit coup de soleil
là-dessus hein ouais ouais c'est pe très
fort
ok je vais aller dans le
champ le soleil on dirait là il arrive à
devant oui pas derrière
ok on fait l'autre ERC ouais voilà on
fait ton plan et tu restes dans l'axe
d'accord ou ou oui compris j'ai compris
j'ai compris ça va ça
va j'ai du vert j'ai du vert ah
etmi on attends on
attend tu me dis allez moteur
att ça se trouve ça va pas marcher il en
a allez vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y ça va
marcher vas-y
vas-y pas trop vite pas trop vite pas
trop vite pas trop vite c'est pour pas
que ça chouffle tu vois qu' pas d'accord
mais pas trop vite quand même parce
qu'on pourra pas s'en servir si tu as
des trucs qui montent devant l'objectif
en C pas t'en servir non
plus tout va bien voilà tout va
bien et là le coton derrière ah non tu
l'as pas pris ok c'est pas
grave oh le coton il est magnifique là
c'est vraiment le champ de coton qu'on a
le plus de c'est beau ça comme plan là
comme c'est beau c'est magnifique ça ce
coton tuas fait un petit de flou non
ouais mais attends là non ça été trop
vite attends on va faire a ok coupe la
T
vasy pas
serré que je m'arrête ah si ça va allez
vas-y continue moi je vais
descendre
pas trop vite pas trop vite c'est pas
facile en
de'en va et tout c'est les mec allez
tomber
alors un petit mouvement de monter comme
tu veux
LG don un petit peu de mouvement à ça tu
vois voilà c'est joli c'est très joli
c'est très très beau ça voilà tu faire
en gros plan un mec dans hauteur qui
ramasse c'est très très beau
ça c'est très très joli
ça
on voit bien là ce qu'ils font
là tu pouvais quand tu auras fini ce
plan s télé ou
ouais les arbres qu'il sont beau ces
arbres verts là sont
sublimes P un peu à droite ou je sais je
per les références grav non non mais ou
oui je
sais le truc c'est que l'écran il est un
peu de moi ça m'aide pas du tout en
fait on va te leesser t
shooter un peu en traviol
c'est pas
facile non il ramasse plus rien sur nous
là REC comment je les
pané
ah c'est joli ça c'est super beau
ça que tu rentres un plus dedans
j'arrive parce que la télévision on
verra plus
rien beaucoup d'hommes qui
travaillent des femmes
mais
tout le monde s'y
met des hommes d'ailleurs
là
il nous regarde tous
là si je fermer la porte les mecs me
regarder moi
ah
ouais il merci super allez les mecs
allez après ce plan là faudra changer de
cassette voilà il a S met il y en a un
qui s'y
met oh fait
chier ah tuas une femme là qui
travaille à l'extrême droite elle
travaille
j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive CELI qui va
aller sur une bon femme
là VO tu la vois est à droite de
l'arbre pass à
gauche
gr le bosser en tout
cas une femme
ça c'est un mec attends attends on va y
aller on va y
aller merci te reproches pas te
reproches
pas on les presque en fin de
bande
génial génial
génial
génial on finit la bande sur eux c'est
super
oh super super
super ça c'est le bon plan ça c'est le
plan voilà ça c'est le plan vu du ciel
tu descends voilà tu descends il reste
pas grandchose quelques secondes finit
on finit on finit làdessus ça c'est
super voilà ça c'est le plan qu' nous
fallait voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà on finit la bande
là-dessus
oh il n regarde merde merde
merde pas tout le temps pas tout le
temps pas ah oui si tu veux faire une
sortie